du möchtest uns aber auch berichten ralf
über ein aufreger mit blick auf die
öffentlich rechtlichen fernsehsender auf
zdf offenbar gibt es ein islamismus
problem das scheint eigentlich fast
schon ein strukturelles problem zu sein
wir hatten vor kurzem jahr die
moderatorin der sendung quarks das
wissenschaftsmagazin wdr im wdr die sich
lange zeit in der antisemitischen und in
der schwer
islamistischen szene aufgehalten hat wir
haben jetzt eine junge autorin die
comedy macht aber auch stand up poetry
slam und auf anti israelischen
demonstrationen war die eine hamas nahe
jugendorganisation unterstützt hier
sehen wir ein paar dinge wenn ich kurz
doch der brechener frei die sie auf
ihrem instagram kanal gepostet hat da
sehen wir themen todenhöfer haben aber
auch am anfang hier das ja ein comic
gesehen ein völlig klar antisemitisches
comic das sind also dinge die sie auf
instagram kostet ja inzwischen hat sie
es ein bisschen bereinigt aber das waren
zum beispiel so comics mit stereotypen
zionistischen darstellungen mit
hakennase wie man es eigentlich auch
sehr düsteren zeiten kennt und die junge
frau ist anfang zwanzig und soll jetzt
kommen die autorin werden für eine
comedy sendung beim zdf und man fragt
sich natürlich ob das zdf irgendwo
vielleicht etwas übersehen hat ob die
sich gekümmert haben darum wen sie da
eigentlich einstellen die junge frau hat
stand up nummern abgeliefert die sehr
lustig waren auch gerade mit
migrationsthemen aber das geht natürlich
überhaupt nicht und das scheint
folgenlos bleiben zu wollen weil das zdf
das bisher nicht wusste oder weil das
zdf das billigend in kauf nimmt das zdf
hält sich weitgehend bedeckt verschanzt
sich so hinter allgemeinen humanität
floskeln die man selbstverständlich die
standards werden gebaut und man achte
sehr gut darauf aber zu dem einzelnen
fall wollte man sich nicht äußern das
ist eine wagenburg mentalität die man
kennt wo man erst mal alles abwiegelt
und selbstverständlich haben wir alles
im blick und an nichts falsch gemacht so
wird es aber nicht weitergehen also man
muss einfach auch sehen dass man
bestimmte sachen
einfach eine gewisse mentale hygiene
hält und es kann nicht sein dass man
sich darüber erregt dass die auch freie
in leipzig nicht ins hotel kann weil ein
davidstern trägt dann das und solche
sachen hier duldet da muss eine klare
linie gezogen werden
[Musik]